[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti e grazie dell'invito
Io sono qui grazie al mio lavoro perché
da oltre 20 anni Lavoro in un museo
unico al mondo lo posso dire senza
problemi di smentita si tratta del museo
tattile statale Omero e sta ad Ancona
Ecco la nostra sede la sede è già molto
bella si tratta della mole vanvitelliana
di Ancona e quindi Come spesso accade il
museo già uno scrigno nello scrigno Ma
questo è anche qualcosa di più e ed è
soprattutto l'idea da cui è nato che è
forte è l'idea che mi piace raccontare e
mi piace il pensiero che possa superare
barriere confini e e l'idea di due
persone di due anconetani Aldo e Daniela
Grassini Tutto nasce dalla loro passione
e dalla loro esperienza di grandissimi
viaggiatori ma parlo di viaggiatori nel
senso di persone che hanno visitato i
cinque continenti che hanno viaggiato da
sempre quando viaggiare voleva dire
avere problemi con i visti con i
passaporti superare le Cortine e andare
al di là del muro di Berlino l'hanno
fatto con accompagnatori con am am con
familiari ma soprattutto con persone che
condividono con loro una passione uno
dei tanti impegni quello della lingua
dell'Esperanto avrete sentito dire a
fasi alterne di questa lingua nata a
tavolino da un giovane ragazzo polacco
per superare le barriere linguistiche
per mettere insieme sullo stesso livello
tutte le culture e tutte le popolazioni
questo è l'esperanto E vedrete che
questo ha a che fare con la nostra
storia perché si parla di superamento e
di barriere
Allora cosa succedeva Allora come nel
passato ma anche adesso quando dopo un
convegno dopo una conferenza di
esperanto viene organizzato una visita
al museo a un parco archeologico o a
un'area appunto a un'area culturale
tutti partono e vanno per questa gita si
arriva davanti alla porta del museo Ma
lì c'è qualcosa poi che non va perché ad
Aldo e Daniela non viene permesso di
vedere questo può sembrare un po' Strano
no Perché cosa hanno diverso dall'altro
non vi ho detto una cosa Aldo e Daniela
sono due persone cieche sono due non
vedenti Quindi cosa vuol dire per loro
vedere vuol dire toccare vuol dire usare
le mani per vedere vuol dire usare un
altro strumento per arrivare allo stesso
obiettivo potete immaginare e
sicuramente appunto penserete che Beh in
effetti toccare nei musei proprio una
cosa che non si fa è proprio il divieto
per assoluto che tutti insegnano quando
andiamo
quando siamo bambini però questo come
tutte le cose Va può essere messo in
discussione e quindi la loro esperienza
ha fatto sì che sia nato nelle loro
menti Ma poi in pratica proprio nelle
con le loro forze hanno iniziato quella
che noi chiamiamo noi me e i colleghi
del museo Una pacifica rivoluzione
Allora la prima fase consisteva in
questo loro viaggiando provavano a
parlare con i custodi con i direttori a
volte facevano anche chiamare la Polizia
o i Carabinieri Quindi potete immaginare
è successo di tutto A volte i custodi
facevano finta di nulla e li facevano
toccare a volte gli accompagnatori erano
furbi non si facevano vedere a volte il
direttore scendeva li conosceva e capiva
la situazione Cioè per la prima volta
iniziava a riflettere su questa
richiesta altre volte invece succedeva
di tutto e di più Insomma il peggio
proprio di ritorno da un viaggio da una
vacanza in Germania erano
particolarmente frustrati erano
particolarmente arrabbiati perché lì
veramente non avevano spuntato nulla Non
avevano toccato nulla e nello stesso
tempo ascoltavano le descrizioni il il
divertimento e i commenti degli altri
perché poi questa esperienza del museo
faceva sì che appunto andando in gruppo
loro si sentivano particolarmente
esclusi esclusi due volte da questa cosa
E questa questa frustrazione questo
sentimento negativo Però per nostra
fortuna l'hanno l'hanno saputo
trasformare in cucina nella loro casa di
Ancona davanti a un piatto di pomodori
freschi racconta Daniela la moglie hanno
avuto questa hanno detto per la prima
volta questa parola perché prima di
cambiare diciamo il divieto in assoluto
non facciamo noi qualcosa di concreto
non creiamo un luogo un museo dove tutti
tutti possano toccare Quindi l'obiettivo
non era solo quello di fare qualcosa per
loro stessi superare una carenza per non
vedenti ma di fare qualcosa per tutti e
così hanno fatto dall'85 al 93 hanno
messo insieme le forze l' energie hanno
coinvolto il comune di Ancona la regione
Marche l'unione cechie ipovedenti e nel
1993 è nato il museo tattile
Omero abbiamo quindi compiuto da poco 30
anni e il museo Ovviamente si è
ingrandito per nostra fortuna perché è
una bella storia perché il museo da
piccolo da locale è diventato un museo
statale è un museo della direzione dei
musei delle Marche è un museo del nostro
Ministero ma è rimasta ad Ancona e
quindi è importante anche il suo legame
con la città il museo si è ingrandito
Quindi siamo in questa sede Come avete
visto definitiva molto molto bella e
prestigiosa ma soprattutto il museo Da
sempre è visitato da qualsiasi tipo di
pubblico sia come età che come genere
che come provenienza perché tutt'ora
dopo 30 anni ve lo giuro siamo ancora
l'unico museo tattile statale al mondo E
questa Già direi che sarebbe una bella
storia bellissima storia diciamo
molto insomma con una bella bel finale
ma non è questo non era questo
l'obiettivo di Alde Daniela l'obiettivo
da sempre era di creare un luogo e così
è dove tutti possano toccare perché vi
dico una cosa vi svelo un segreto il
tatto ce l'abbiamo tutti non solo i
ciechi e soprattutto non dobbiamo
pensare ai supereroi quando pensiamo
alle persone disabili non dobbiamo
pensare a persone con appunto un tatto
straordinario un udito bionico un
olfatto fuori dalla norma No quello che
ci differenzia È l'educazione è
l'allenamento ed è soprattutto questo mi
ci tengo molto a dirlo la curiosità e la
fame che queste persone hanno di
sperimentare di fare esperienze e quindi
la quello che nasce diciamo per una
mancanza Per colmare un diritto e per
superare una barriera diventa Come
spesso accade un arricchimento per tutti
il Ma da dove viene questa idea in un
certo senso Qual è il motore che ha
spinto Aldo e Daniela a a creare questo
luogo e a farlo vivere e a studiare e a
continuare a riflettere su questo tema
come Aldo ci ricorda tutti i giorni
perché lui ancora è il nostro presidente
lavora con noi è la vita che ci ricorda
che siamo
multisensoriali è la vita che ci dice
che abbiamo a disposizione più sensi più
Strumenti più Medium E che soprattutto
ogni senso ci dà un'informazione diversa
ci dà delle emozioni diverse ci dà delle
nozioni diverse Quindi quando uno pensa
ma un non vedente può capire un'opera
d'arte può vedere davvero con le mani Sì
perché è il punto di partenza che cambia
qualcuno vede con le mani qualcuno con
gli occhi qualcuno è più uditivo
qualcuno è più il fattivo ma mettendo
insieme queste La maggior parte il più
possibile di queste informazioni
iniziali poi tutto quello che avviene
veramente avviene nella nostra mente con
la rielaborazione e quando c'è la magia
dell'esperienza estetica dell'arte ci si
uniscono anche le emozioni e le
memorie Ecco quindi un'altra parola
chiave per noi che spesso è difficile
che si abbini al museo il piacere il
museo e l'arte sono uno dei piaceri
della vita quando accompagno Aldo per
mostre o per musei dopo che lui è
riuscito a toccare delle opere che non
ha mai visto degli Artisti per lui
sconosciuti io gli chiedo Aldo ti è
piaciuta questa mostra Ti è piaciuto
questo scultore E lui mi risponde non mi
è piaciuto io sono felice perché l'arte
ha questa capacità ma non è insita non è
scontata non ce lo insegnano a scuola è
un qualcosa che deve venire perché
Perché io posso andare nei musei da
sempre perché posso farlo con chi voglio
e perché mi sento accolto si parla molto
di accessibilità No questo è il nostro
argomento mentre prima accessibilità era
un qualcosa di settoriale Adesso per
fortuna si sta capendo che accessibilità
è già la persona che ti sorride appena
arrivi in un museo è l'accoglienza sono
le informazioni chiare sul sito internet
sono tantissime cose sono tutto quello
che noi facciamo al museo tutti i giorni
ma un'altra riflessione volevo fare con
voi appunto ogni senso ha una
diversa Ognuno di noi ha un senso
prevalente ma torniamo un attimo al
tatto perché ovviamente il museo tattile
è il nostro punto di partenza il tatto
ha una caratteristica diversa unica
rispetto agli altri sensi lavora solo
nella vicinanza lavora El eliminando le
distanze il tatto non può lavorare da
remoto pensate voi come ci siamo sentiti
noi con il covid è vero che siamo alla
mo vanvitelliana chea un Lazzaretto
Quindi eravamo già diciamo nel luogo
giusto Ma noi siamo un museo tattile e
nella prima fase dell'emergenza covid
tutti voi si ricorderanno il problema e
la causa di tutto sembrava essere il
tatto sto parlando proprio di quella
fase dei guanti la fase in cui gli
operatori sanitari non potevano toccare
nessuno neanche i loro cari in cui i
malati non potevano appunto ricevere
nessun tipo di contatto in cui io
ricordo benissimo Si portavano i cani i
cani guida i cani in ospedale per far
per essere accarezzate dagli operatori
sanitari proprio perché c'era necessità
e una persona non può stare più di
troppo tempo senza questo eh senso
questo perché Perché il tatto a
differenza degli altri è un senso che
nutre e tantissimi studi
scientifici insomma per fortuna stanno
portando avanti queste ricerche e ormai
è chiaro è risaputo e ribadito che un
bambino che Viene nutrito ma non viene
accarezzato non cresce allo stesso modo
di un altro bambino quindi in quella
fase assurda che tutti abbiamo vissuto
il tatto che è nutrimento che di solito
è cura era anche la causa Veramente non
era difficile poter pensare di uscire da
questo da questo angolo buio ancora una
volta noi del museo siamo andati a
cercare aiuto da chi dagli artisti
dall'arte perché noi questo sappiamo
fare e in quella fase lì in cui molti di
noi si si sentivano assolutamente
inutili Noi abbiamo detto cosa possiamo
fare un museo tattile chiuso che lavora
da remoto sembrava tutto surreale e e
invece ci è venuto incontro uno dei
nostri documenti base importanti che
citiamo sempre il manifesto del tattilo
di Filippo Tommaso Marinetti qualcuno di
voi magari ha sentito dire di Marinetti
del Futurismo dei tanti manifesti il
tattilo è meno conosciuto e invece è
importante perché è stato scritto
pubblicato a Parigi nel 21 ma è stato
scritto insieme anche la moglie dopo
un'esperienza anche questa straordinaria
dell'autore Marinetti si è rolato ha
fatto la Prima Guerra Mondiale si è
trovato per lunghissime notti nelle
trincee al buio Ecco qua Io mi io penso
sempre a questo Io penso ai suoi
commilitoni che chi faceva la guardia
chi dormiva chi pregava chi scriveva le
a casa Chi Piangeva lui cosa faceva
faceva l'artista faceva l'esteta e ha
usato queste Trincee al buio per
iniziare a fare gli esercizi sul tatto
lui è stato il primo dal punto di vista
artistico a riflettere su come il il
tatto funziona sul fatto che sia un
senso semplice per così dire Ma vada
allenato ne ha fatto un manifesto
bellissimo che vi invito a cercare e
all'interno di questo manifesto lui
Addirittura eclea già degli esercizi del
tatto che bisogna fare per tenere
allenato al al terzo esercizio vado a
leggere e dice Si consiglia di tenere le
mani inguanta per alcuni giorni in
maniera da condensare il desiderio di
esperienze tattili è stato una una
rivelazione ho trovato lì il motivo tra
virgolette per cui aveva senso anche
tenere i guanti per un periodo avrebbe
avuto senso solo se poi no in previsione
di della del ritorno della normalità
tutti saremmo tornati con più
consapevolezza Questo era l'unica cosa
da fare non potevamo fare altro potevamo
aspettare ma c'è modo e modo di
aspettare e di reagire e per fortuna
siamo qua tutti seduti vicini senza
restrizioni e ed è già appunto un
miracolo Però come siamo tornati da
questa cosa molti di noi non lo sanno
ancora forse presto non abbiamo
rielaborato tutta questa cosa qua di
sicuro il museo è riaperto la gente
continua e torna a toccare è ovvio noi
come prima usiamo gel disinfettanti
usiamo i guanti nel momento in cui c'è
bisogno di usarli se ci sono delle
opere diciamo fragili ma quello che
cerchiamo di combattere è il tabù che
c'è sul tatto perché è troppo
caricato nelle nostre culture di Tabù
religiosi culturali e sanitari il tatto
è assolut ente uno appunto de dei sensi
e soprattutto l'immagine tattile è molto
interessante e noi inv vedenti al museo
mero possiamo toccare e guardare insieme
possiamo far suonare e far parlare
un'opera d'arte perché anche l'immagine
sonora è altrettanto
interessante Quindi quello che in un
certo senso Vogliamo invitare a fare
appunto venendo al nostro museo è un po'
allenarci Ecco non solo allenare i
muscoli ma allenare i sensi
Perm essere più diciamo pronti a
percepire tutto quello che abbiamo
intorno per imparare anche a raccontarlo
in maniera diversa perché anche non solo
la nostra società una società visiva e
virtuale Anzi direi ma anche il nostro
linguaggio è molto visivo e invece la
ricchezza della multisensorialità serve
a chi manca di un senso perché comunque
compensa e serve a tutti noi appunto per
vivere appieno di più la
vita quindi non mi resta che invitarvi
ovviamente al museo amo per vedere
appunto per toccare le opere sia
originali che capolavori d'arte perché
appunto la nostra collezione è formata
sia di copie al vero come la Venere di
Milo come il Davide Michelangelo come la
Pietà ma anche di opere d'arte originale
e modellini
architettonici Vi invitiamo appunto a
venire con a portare i piccoli a venire
con i grandi in ogni
occasione ma soprattutto Vi invitiamo
appunto a fare un'esperienza che non vi
lasci uguale a come siete entrati che vi
faccia riscoprire appunto dei sensi
sopiti e soprattutto come dice Aldo con
una frase che vorrei usare per chiudere
perché secondo me connette tutto quello
che ho detto fino adesso non puoi non
toccare ciò che ami e quindi il il tatto
è proprio il senso dell'emotività il
senso dell'affettività e quindi il senso
della vita
grazie